مشاهدينا دعونا ننقل لكم هذه الصور
المباشره التي تاتينا الان لوزير الدفاع
الامريكي لويد اوستن والذي يصل العاصمه
الكوريه الجنوبيه سيول اوستن قال قبل
وصوله ان الولايات المتحده وكوريا
الجنوبيه ستجريان تدريبات نظريه لتعزيز
الردع ضد التهديدات النوويه وايضا اضاف في
مقال بعنوان التحالف يقف على اهبه
الاستعداد نشرته وكاله يهاب للانباء قال
ان واشنطن وسيول ستجريان تدريبات نظريه
حيث تتم مناقشته سيناريوهات معقده تركز
على التهديدات النوويه في شبه الجزيره
الكوريه اصلا يزور سيول للمره الثالثه
طبعا بصفته وزيرا للدفاع ومن المقرر ان
يلتقي نظيره الكوري الجنوبي لجونك شوب
رئيس يوم سوق يونس
طبعا ياتي هذا في ظل تصاعد التوتر ما بين
كوريا الشماليه وكوريا
الجنوبيه وطبعا اطلاق كوريا الشماليه عدد
من الصواريخ اا فيما يعتبر على مستوى
المجتمع الدولي وايضا
الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه على انه
تهديد
من التقاء الولايات المتحده في اكثر من
مره واخرها هذه الزياره الان وهذه
المناورات التي تجري تاكد دائما دعمها
لكوريا الجنوبيه في مواجهه اي تهديد من
كوريا الشماليه اذا هذا وصول لوزير الدفاع
الامريكي لكوريا الجنوبيه في رساله واضحه
الى كوريا الشماليه واي تهديد همم كان من
تلك المنطقه
[موسيقى]